[MUSIC PLAYING]
TARUN JAIN: Good
morning, everyone,
and thank you for being here
for an early morning session.
I know it's been a long
week for a lot of you.
I hope the Google Next was
fun and exciting for you.
For me, personally,
it was pretty
inspiring to see how far
the ecosystem has evolved,
and all the
opportunities it kind of
presents to our partners,
to our developers,
and to our end users.
The topic today we're going to
talk about is Google Assistant,
and how to build your
experiences on Google
Assistant.
I'm Tarun Jain, and
I'm a product manager
on Google Assistant.
MATTHEW CARROLL: And I'm Matt.
I'm a developer
programs engineer
on the Google Assistant.
TARUN JAIN: So
let's jump right in.
So when we think of
Google Assistant,
there are few trends that
I'm going to talk about
before we set the stage
on how do you build
your app for Google Assistant.
We are at an amazing point in
technology where we are really
pushing the envelope
on what can technology
do to make things
happen for the users,
to help them do things in a
lot more seamless and efficient
way.
The first thing is
that interactions are
more natural than ever before.
So what does that mean?
If I think of a simple task,
like I'm taking a very, very
simple example as, do I need to
take an umbrella to work today?
Or I drive up from
the peninsula,
so do I need to carry my
jacket to San Francisco?
And so on.
How do you think about it?
You check what the weather
is, what time of the day
it's probably going to rain.
This probably
aligns with the time
I actually take a walk down
for my commute to the train.
I should carry an
umbrella, right?
Now imagine Google Assistant
doing that for you, which is,
it has access to what your
calendar is, what your schedule
looks like for the day.
It knows how often and
what times of the day
do you actually take the train.
It knows what the weather
is for the rest of the day,
and can help you and
can recommend to you
that you need to carry
an umbrella today.
And then the next thing is
kind of being more proactive
about it.
A very, very simple task, but
we have the building blocks
to do some of these things.
Now imagine, what should
I order for food tonight?
Or what my weekend
plans should be,
or which movie I should be
watching this Friday, and so
on.
So the user expectations
around interaction with Google
and on other
surfaces that we have
are becoming a lot more natural.
The second thing I
want to talk about
is the Assistant platform.
The Assistant platforms are
becoming a lot more mainstream.
So think back a few years ago.
If you want to do something,
you want to go somewhere,
you want to buy something, you
would go to your mobile phone
or to your desktop
or your laptop
based on where you
are to look that up
and kind of do that task.
But now with Google
Assistant, you
have Google Home
sitting in your kitchen.
You have Android TV, that
is Assistant powered,
in your living room.
You have Android Auto when
you're driving, and so on.
So users are using all
these computing touchpoints
to actually get things done
no matter where they are.
They want to be able to
talk to their brands,
they want to be
able to get things
done while they're actually
busy cooking in the kitchen.
So imagine your hands are
occupied while you're cooking.
You want to be able to ask
Google Home at that point
of time is that, what do I do
next with the pasta I'm making?
And so on.
So Assistant is becoming
lot more mainstream.
These computing
touchpoints are everywhere,
and they're growing as we speak.
And both of these are feeding
into how the user experience
and expectations are changing.
The needs are evolving.
We see users becoming a lot more
curious, a lot more demanding,
and a lot more
impatient with what
they expect from the platform.
Obviously personalized.
Lot more users expect their
experiences to be personalized.
You might think this is obvious
and you've seen this before.
But from it being
a nice-to-have,
personalization is
becoming our table stakes.
So I'll give an example.
Just the Google queries that
we see which end with "for me,"
like "the best restaurant for
me" or "weekend plans for me"
have grown up 60%
in the last year.
And that's a big number
based on the denominator
we are talking about.
Users expect their experience
to be a lot more real time.
They want to be able to get
things done there and then.
A few anecdotes here.
When you think of shopping,
more and more people
want same day delivery.
More and more people want,
actually, two hour delivery
windows.
When it comes to travel,
the same day travel category
has grown up by more than
100% in the last year or so,
which means people are looking
a lot more for hotels to book
tonight or flights they want to
today or tomorrow, and so on.
So actions and tasks that
people want to accomplish
are becoming a lot
more real time,
are becoming a lot more, I
want it in the next 24 hours,
and so on.
And with that comes
everywhere they are.
Users want things to be done
no matter where they are.
And as I talked about, as
these computing touchpoints are
becoming omnipresent, they
could be in your home,
in your living room, in your
car, in a washing machine,
everywhere.
They want to be able to
interact with the right partners
at that point of time
to get things done.
They are seeking information
no matter where they are.
And we have touchpoints with
users throughout their day.
So no matter where.
So if you think of
your full day schedule,
in the morning during
the morning routine,
people reach out to Google Home
to check what their day looks
like, what the calendar is,
top news, talk updates, music,
and so on.
During the commute,
they use Google Maps
to go where they are going.
During the day, it's
about Google email,
it's about their calendar,
it's about Google search
for productivity.
And in the evening as
they are winding down,
it's about playing
something on YouTube,
or even playing a few apps and
games on the Android ecosystem.
So we see users use their
experiences with Google
services throughout the day.
And users expect all those
experiences to be connected.
So if you think
through the whole day,
they move from Google
Home device to,
let's say, a mobile phone
to their car to a laptop
and back to the living
room TV and so on.
And the expectation is that
all these experiences are
connected, they seamlessly flow
from one surface to another,
and these experiences
are seamless.
And one of the big goals
that we have with Assistant
is to help users
get things done.
How do we actually provide
enough value to users
where we are doing
things for them?
So we have three
customer journeys
that we prioritize
and we focus on.
So when we actively
think of use cases that
matter for our users, they fall
in one of these three buckets.
So streamline your
morning at home.
How do we make sure
that when you're
trying to get out of your
house, we can actually help you
by getting things done so
you have less to worry about
and you can move out
of the house quickly?
So these could be
very simple things,
like turn off the thermostat
when I'm leaving, to something
a little bit more
fancy, which is
order my coffee so that I can
pick it up on the way to work.
So that's one big
area of focus for us,
and we'll go into this in
a little bit more detail.
Then do more while
you are on the go.
You could be on a commute,
you could be driving.
How do we help
you do more things
while you are in that mode?
And then finally, have a
relaxing evening at home.
So when you are unwinding,
when you are back home,
you want to spend time
with family and so on.
How do we take off some of the
mundane chores off your hands
and do it for you so that you
get to spend time doing things
that you really want to do?
So here's an example.
We launched Starbucks on
Assistant a few weeks ago.
And this is a very good use
case that Starbucks implemented.
"Order my usual from Starbucks."
"OK, getting Starbucks."
It asks you for the drink
that you want, the location,
and places the order
for you so that you
have a coffee ready for you by
the time you get to the shop.
So Starbucks realized
that they have
a lot of users who
come to their stores
and order the same
coffee everyday.
It's pretty much like a
morning habit for a lot of us.
And on an Assistant
Service, they
picked up a use case
that matches or aligns
with that morning habit.
It is less about, you can come
in and order anything you want,
and all the other fancy
scenarios that you
would want to be there.
But they focused
on a specific use
case, which is, this
is what a morning
routine for a lot of users look
like, is I just want my order.
This is the usual
coffee I have every day.
And knowing all the
customizations they offer,
this is what the user orders
every day in the mornings.
So can we make it
seamless for the user?
Can we add that convenience
and value to the user?
And this is the examples
that I'm talking about.
The ecosystem is
evolving very fast.
We have thousands and thousands
of apps on Assistant now
which are actively building a
lot of brands on the platform.
We believe this is the right
time for our developers
to start building their
experiences on Assistant.
So why is this the right time?
Assistant is on 500
million plus devices,
on 5,000 plus different kinds
of devices that are out there.
So it includes the
voice only devices.
It includes the phones which
have a screen and voice.
And then through the
rest of the year,
we are launching things like
smart screens and so on.
So there is a big distribution
of the devices that we have.
It's a big value add
for developers to be
an early mover in the vertical.
They are seen as an innovator.
And a good way for them
to set the precedent
on what a great experience
in their vertical looks like.
It's a great way for
developers and for brands
to connect with new users
who are on that platform.
But also add a lot of delight
for their loyal customers,
or for their repeat customers.
And then, as I said, this
is a two-year-old platform.
So this is evolving.
We are making a lot
of progress on this.
So you get to be part of a fast
evolving platform, and shape
what that looks like based
on the businesses you are in.
So I think with this,
I'll hand it over to Matt.
He'll walk us through,
how do you actually
go and build an experience
like that on Assistant?
MATTHEW CARROLL: Thanks, Tarun.
So the next 20
minutes or so, I'm
going to go over all
the steps you need
to do to build your own action.
And everything I'm
going to go over today
you can start building today.
So first, what are we
going to walk through here?
On the left, you can see a
screen of an Assistant action
directory page.
So this is what
your users will see
when you share out your action.
And we're going to
go over an action
called Which Language,
which tells people
about programming languages.
The other two
screenshots you can see
are users actually
interacting with your action,
getting information, and
scrolling through lists,
and talking to the action.
So actions are conversational.
So what's the
actual conversation
that we want our users to have?
So first, the user will talk to
the Google Assistant and say,
I would like to talk
to Which Language.
Or you can replace
the name of your app
once you've built it, talk
to the name of your action.
And then the Google Assistant
will hand off the conversation
to our action.
The action will have a
chance to introduce itself,
tell the user what it can do.
And then the conversation
will continue
with the user responding
and your action responding
until the user has the
information they need
or the action accomplished.
So how does this
work on the back end?
So once a user talks
to the Google Assistant
and indicates they want
to talk to an action,
the Google Assistant will route
that request to your action.
You'll have a chance to do
any API calls, database look
ups, whatever you need to do to
accomplish whatever the user is
asking you to do.
And then respond with the
information or the response
you'd like to send to the user.
And then that will be forwarded
through the Google Assistant
to the user.
So the first step in building
an action like this is design.
So in this kind of new space
with conversational actions,
if you start with
your text stack
or start developing first,
you can end up in a position
where most of the code
you've written isn't useful.
Or you can kind of develop
yourself into a corner
where a lot of the code
you have isn't useful.
So design is incredibly
important with conversations.
So make sure to
start with design.
The first part of
design is a persona.
So this is kind of the
philosophy behind your brand.
And if you already are working
with a UX or other team that's
for your brand that has
come up with a persona,
this is a great
time to use that.
If you don't already
have a persona
for your brand or your
action, the first thing
you want to start with
is just adjectives.
So this is just
things that you want
people to think of when
they think of your action.
So things like geeky, and
over eager, or impatient.
They don't all have to be
very positive adjectives,
but something that embodies what
you're trying to get across.
And from there, you
can kind of move this
into a character model.
So something that
kind of embodies
a lot of the adjectives.
And then from there,
combine all those together
to come up with a complete
description of the personality
that you'd like to convey.
So after you've
decided on a persona,
the next step is
choosing a voice.
So you can send texts
to the Google Assistant,
and that will be
translated into speech.
And you have several
voices to choose from
to make sure it's consistent
with your persona.
But for that extra
level of personality,
you can record your own
voices and audio clips
and send those to the
Google Assistant, which will
be forwarded on to the user.
Or have a voice actor
record those for you.
So now that we've got a persona
and we know what kind of voice
we want to have, the
next step is actually
writing the dialogue and
writing out the conversation
that you want to
have with the user.
So you want to focus on
some of those use cases
that Tarun was talking about
earlier, those quick and easy
use cases to get something done.
And start with very
limited use cases
and very quick interactions,
and then expand from there.
And then once you
have a few sets
of dialogues and happy
paths for different things
that your action can do,
start creating a high level
flow of how your conversation
is going to branch,
and how each of
those happy path is
going to play with each other.
This is a great time
to revisit your persona
and really make sure that
the dialogue you're creating
embodies that persona, and
the personality of your action
comes through.
So now that we have some
dialogue, how do we build it?
So first, we need to set up
our development environment.
And the place where
you're going to start,
the action is on Google Console.
So this is where everything
about your action
lives, from the
Assistant Directory page
that we saw earlier,
from setting up
testing and deployment.
You can see how your action
is doing with Analytics,
and setting up other
advanced features
that I'm going to go over.
So the actions on Google
Console uses the same projects
that you're used to from Google
Cloud Platform and Firebase,
so you can have all your
resources in one project
and easily accessible
to your action.
So now that we know
where we want to start,
how do we actually
understand the user?
So the Google Assistant
will transcribe
the voice of the user,
and sends you the text.
But how do we get from
that text to understanding
what the user wants, and what
the user's trying to get at?
So this is where the
Dialogflow comes in.
Dialogflow is a natural
language understanding platform
that allows you to understand
the intent behind what
the user is saying, and also
extracts important elements
of the user's speech out.
So things like
times and dates when
you're trying to
schedule an appointment,
or other custom parameters
like product names.
Dialogflow also helps you
manage how the dialogue actually
flows, and allows you to
enable the branching that we
talked about earlier when
you're creating your dialogue.
So where does Dialogflow
fit in the stack here?
So after the user
says, in the case
they want to talk
to your action,
that request will be
forwarded to Dialogflow.
And that will trigger
the welcome intent,
and then we'll have
a chance to respond
to introduce our action.
So how do we set that up?
So we start in the
Actions Console
here, and indicate
what languages
we want to start with.
And then start building
with Dialogflow.
So you start building.
You create a Dialogflow
agent, and there's already
a welcome intent
created for you.
You can see in the
screenshot here, we're
removing some of
the generic welcomes
that just say hi
or hello, and we're
going to add a custom
response specifically
for our action that
introduces our action,
and kind of tells
people what they can do.
So now you can see that we can
just write in a text response
into Dialogflow.
So this is just a
static response.
Since this isn't
really going to change,
we're just going to create a
couple different variations.
And one of these two variations
will be surfaced to the user.
And we'll ask them
a question of,
what programming language
do you want to know about,
so that they know what
our action is capable of
and can respond appropriately.
So after we ask the
question, what language you
want to know about, you can
think of all the various things
people might say.
There's probably
thousands that you
could think of if
you had enough time,
and there's probably
thousands more
that you wouldn't think of
that people will actually
ask your action.
So this is really where the
power of Dialogflow comes in.
If we can enter all these
examples that are on the screen
here as training
phrases for Dialogflow,
and we can add a new intent
called the Which Language
intent, Dialogflow
will use these examples
as training for a
machine learning model
so that any of these
examples will be captured
in the Which Language intent.
But the machine
learning model will also
capture any other phrases
that the user says
that have the similar
intent of wanting to know
about a programming language.
So this is how we actually
add the training phrases.
So in this Which Language
intent that we create,
we'll add some
training phrases here.
And then Dialogflow will train
using these phrases as samples
so we can capture these
phrases and others.
You'll also notice that one
of these words is highlighted.
That is Dialogflow
recognizing an entity.
So we need to know which
programming language they're
actually talking about.
So we'll need to extract out
the name of that programming
language.
So that's what
we'll do next here.
So you can create
your own entities
in Dialogflow
using this UI here.
So we have five
programming languages
that we want to support.
And we have them listed
on the left there.
But we also, in
the right column,
have all the synonyms of
those programming languages.
So if someone wanted
to say JavaScript,
they might be on their phone,
and they might just type JS.
So we know that
probably means they're
talking about JavaScript,
so Dialogflow will interpret
that JS as JavaScript
and forward that along
to your back end
so we can do that.
You can also use
CSV uploads if you
have a large list,
or a product catalog,
or a large number of
entities you want to support.
All right, so now here's
what our stack looks like.
We first have the user
asking to talk to our action.
The welcome intent is triggered.
We respond properly.
And then the user asks about a
specific programming language.
That triggers our
Which Language intent.
And then the information about
which language they picked
is going to get sent
to our back end.
And then we're
going to send them
the information about
that programming language.
So how do we actually send that
information to our back end?
So Dialogflow has this
concept called fulfillment,
and you can set up a
web hook for fulfillment
where the HTTP call will
be made to any URL you
specify with information
about the request.
So which intent was matched, the
original text the user actually
said, any parameters or entities
like the programming language
we defined earlier so that you
can know what the user wants
to do, and have
all the information
you need to respond to properly.
To get up and running
really quickly,
we also have an inline editor
with Firebase functions
so you don't have to
set up a web server.
So now we're getting
into actually writing
some code for our fulfillments.
So first, we just start with
a very simple map of the five
programming
languages we support,
and the information
that we want to send
to the user about each
one of those languages
that we'll use in just a second.
So this is kind of a
basic template of what
you need to do in fulfillment.
So there is an action on
Google Client Library that
helps us parse out the requests
coming from Dialogflow,
and also compile a
response properly
to be forwarded to the user.
So first, we're
importing the library.
And I'm setting up
some boilerplate.
And then that highlighted
section is actually
where we define our responses.
So first, we say app.intent.
So this just
defines which intent
we want to respond to, if you
have multiple intents you'd
like to respond to.
We only have one, and it's
called Which Language.
So we just enter
in Which Language.
And then we have two arguments.
One is the conversation object.
So this is what we use
to add responses that
will be sent back to the user.
And then we have the
language parameter.
So this is the parameter that
Dialogflow captured earlier
that has the value
JavaScript, Kotlin,
or any other programming
language we support.
So the first thing
we do is we take
that map I showed you
earlier, and take the language
and insert that.
And grab the description for
whatever programming language
the user mentioned.
So we're adding that response
about the language first.
And then next,
we're asking if they
want to know about another
language in our second message
there.
And then that last
line there is just
to connect this to Firebase
functions, which is what
this example is running on.
So now we've got something
working end to end.
How do we try it out?
So we go back to
the Actions Console,
and the Actions Console
has a simulator.
So this lets you
do debug and see
exactly what users are going to
see when they try your action.
So you can see here everything
from invocation of saying,
talk to which language.
And your language getting
routed from the Google Assistant
to your action.
You can see how that works,
as well as what happens when--
you can actually enter in what
your users might say and see
what will happen.
You can also see here we have
a difference between what
shows up visually and what is
actually spoken to the user,
as well as a lot of debug
information and helpful things
to help you figure out
if something went wrong.
So far, we've only
been dealing with text.
So if this is just on a
Google Home or a speaker,
that is probably appropriate.
You're only speaking
to the user,
and the Google Assistant can
only actually speak words back.
But what about a lot of
the Assistant devices
that have a screen?
So all the phones, and our
upcoming smart displays,
and other devices
that have screens?
For that, we have a few
different rich message types.
So the first one here
is called a basic card.
So this allows you to have
a large image, a title,
some descriptions, as
well as a button that
can go to links that
can link to websites.
And this is in addition to
the regular text responses
that we defined earlier.
So the actions on
Google Client Library
also has some nice,
convenient methods.
So we can just
create a new card,
enter in all the
different fields
that I mentioned earlier.
And that will be
displayed to the user
properly when we respond.
So another common
type is a list.
So you can use lists for any
kind of product selection,
or whenever you want
to surface to the user
a small group of items and
they need to select one.
So for this, you have the
title, and we can have pictures.
And then there's some
pagination here so
that users can select
from multiple options.
Similarly, the actions
on Google Client Library
also has support
for these list items
so you can create lists
programmatically, and nice
and easily.
Similar to a list is a carousel.
So this uses the same
kind of list selection
as the previous rich response,
but it just surfaces images
a little bit more prominently.
So if whatever you're trying
to get the user to select
is a little bit
more visual, this
is a way to surface
that to your users.
So the last part here
is a way to detect
what surface your users are on.
So if they're on a speaker, you
may want to speak to the user
differently than if
they have a phone
and can see some of these
rich responses that we have.
So we have the capability to
detect what surface they're on,
if they're on a phone or if
that surface has a screen, so we
can respond appropriately.
The last bit that doesn't apply
to our Which Language example,
but can be very useful,
is account linking.
So this allows you to
link your own account
system for your products
to the Google Assistant.
So you can log your users in and
provide contextual information
based on information
you have about
the user in their account.
So this is really
useful if you want
to provide updates or any
information from your products
in the Google Assistant.
All right, now that we've
got everything working
and we tested it out, how do
we get this out to our users?
So the first is just
testing on device.
So once you've enabled
testing in the simulator,
any device that's logged
into the same Google account
that you're testing on
has access to your action.
So you can try it out on your
phone or Google Home device
that's logged into the
same Google account
to see what your users will
actually see when they try out
your action.
After you've tested
it yourself, you
might want to test
it with your team.
So we have an
alpha release where
you can share it with your team
and try it out with your team,
make improvements, and get
ready to deploy to your users.
After you have
something that you
want to deploy to users publicly
or in a small beta group,
you submit your
action for review.
And after about a day,
that will be approved.
And you can publish either
to a small public beta group
of testers or to production.
You can also have
different releases
in each one of these
alpha/beta production channels
so you can provide early release
features to your beta group
to see how it does.
So now that we've gone through
how to build an action,
I'm going to hand
it back to Tarun
to talk about how to grow
your business with it.
TARUN JAIN: Thanks, Matt.
So once you build
a great action,
it's very important for
you to actually start
getting users engaging
with that action.
So the first prerequisite is
you have a good action that you
have built so when you
actually bring users in,
they are delighted and there's
a re-engagement on that.
So there are three verticals,
or three different tenants,
that we think of
when it comes to, how
do you actually start driving
your business on Assistant?
The first one is discovery.
How do you get your action
discovered on Assistant?
The second piece
is monetization,
which is primarily transactions,
physical transactions,
digital transactions, so
you can start monetizing
your experience on Assistant.
And the third is re-engagement.
For your loyal
customers, customers
who have come and engaged
with your experience
before, how do you get them
back into the experience?
And we'll talk about a
bunch of different tools
that we have available so you
can kind of accomplish that.
So let's talk about
discovery first.
Imagine you have
launched the app
that Matt was talking about.
And how do you get
more and more users
to see what that app
is and find that out?
There are a bunch of different
ways users can do that.
The first one is
Assistant Directory.
We have Assistant
Directory on the web.
We have Assistant Directory
on iOS and Android devices.
Think of this as the
Play Store for Android.
This is where users
go in and look
for what's new, what's
trending, and so on.
Today, around 30% of the traffic
that a lot of our third parties
get is from Assistant Directory.
So this gets a lot
of volume from users.
And this is how users have been
discovering a lot of new apps.
So what does Assistant
Directory look like?
I'll just go through
that fairly quickly.
One big experience for users is,
they can browse the Assistant
Directory.
They can go through it.
This experience is largely
timely and personalized
to the users.
It's very context specific.
So this browsing
experience might
look different based
on the time of the day,
or based on different
users, and so on.
So if you think of
the browsing piece,
we showed element
suggestions to the users.
In the morning, you might
see order your coffee
or play this playlist.
In the evening, it might be
something different, and so on.
As you scroll down, there are
many different experiences
that show up in browsing.
Your app could be
in What's New, it
could be as part of what is
trending, what is popular,
or what you might like
based what other experiences
that users have
engaged with already.
The other way users interact
with the explore experience I
talked about is through search.
You can actually come and
search for different apps.
We have a taxonomy of around
400 different categories.
When you create
your action, you'll
tag it to one of
these categories
or more of these categories.
So when users go and
look for, let's say,
in the Food and Drink
category, they'll
see all the apps that are
part of that category.
You could also
search for something,
and search triggers
some of these as well.
So specifically when you
think of a categorical browse,
within Food and Drink,
there are subcategories.
You can order food, that's
part of Food and Drink.
And you can see examples
of Domino's there.
But if you are in
the recipes business,
that's the example of
Food Network, which
is part of the Food
and Drink category,
but is about recipes
at that point of time.
So as I said, explore
is a big surface area
where you can actually
have your app,
and drive traffic to your app.
The second one is
an action page.
Every app needs to
have an action page.
This is where you
would come in and talk
about what this action does.
This is how you
reflect your brand.
And think of it as
a pitch to the user
on why should they
try this, right?
So when you think of the
action page specifically,
it has a succinct image
of your brand, and so on.
It talks about why
should user try the app.
It has ratings.
It has recent reviews.
It has stuff like what
your recent release
logs were, and so on.
But fairly importantly, it
has this try experience,
which is users don't have
to install anything here.
They just click on
Try and they can start
talking to your app experience.
So the inertia for
people who try out things
is relatively low.
And that's what we see
with a lot of experiences
is that, if there is a good
experience on the action page,
a lot of people actually
end up trying that app.
So the conversion
rate, if you will,
are fairly high once users
end up on an action page.
So how do you optimize
your action page?
I think no point
in guessing which
is a great experience
on one of these.
But there are four things
that we usually talk about.
Have a crisp image
and a good image.
The title is important for
what you create for your app.
Don't create long titles which
people cannot talk to or cannot
talk about.
It's important to have
a right one there.
Then a good description
is important.
And description is not like
what your company is about
or what you do.
It's about why should a
user try this experience.
So I think, try to think of
it as a pitch to the user.
The last one, which is
actually very important,
is the invocation phrases.
How does a user invoke this?
This is how you're building a
muscle memory for your users.
No matter what name
you create, users
can always say, talk to
French Bulldog Trivia, right?
But what are the other
kind of invocations
that users can actually use?
It could be "ask French
Bulldog trivia about snoring"
or something like that, right?
Create some fun ones.
Create some
interesting ones that
are relevant for your business.
But create multiple
invocation phrases.
You don't know what drives
users to keep coming back again.
When you look
through our logs, you
will see what the
invocation phrases
are more popular for
users, what are not.
And this drives all of
traffic to your app.
So we talked about things
that you can do on your side
by creating a great
action package,
by creating the great user
experience on the explore.
The second big piece is what
we call built-in intents.
We announced built-in
intents a few months ago,
and we continued to build
the platform for it.
So what is built-in intents?
There are a hundred
different ways
people come in and ask
for the same thing based
on their dialect,
based on the slangs,
based on their language,
and locale, and so on.
These are actually
from real logs.
And basically, what the user
is trying to ask for is,
I want to de-stress
myself, right?
And then there are
many different ways
that they come in and they
ask for the same thing.
Now, to expect a
developer like yourself
to think of every
possible phrase,
or what user might be
saying in your vertical,
is fairly difficult. So
what we have is a concept
we call built-in intents.
Built-in intents is nothing,
but it's a standard taxonomy
for actions.
This is how, when a user
says all the things we
saw in the last slide,
we actually translate
that to a single thing
saying, meditate.
And you can sign up for
that built-in intent.
We have lots of built-in
intents already in production.
They are available in the tool.
You can sign up
for any of these.
And we are launching
more and more
throughout the rest of the year.
It's fairly easy to sign
up for a built-in intent
when you go to the
Dialogflow Console.
There's a dropdown of
all the built-in intents
that we've launched.
And you pick and choose one or
more that are relevant to you.
It's important to be right
and relevant about this.
The reason is, you
can imagine if there's
a lot of traffic that
is coming to your app
and users are bouncing off.
That's a bad signal to
our ranking engines.
So you want to be picking up
the right built-in intents that
are relevant for your business.
This has been a big driver of
traffic to a lot of our apps,
and I think it's
important to be selecting
the right built-in intents.
So here's an example of
what it would look like.
There's a built-in
intent for Play Quiz.
A user comes in and says,
I want to play a trivia,
I want to play a quiz, or I
want to play a geography quiz.
Whatever those
invocation phrases are,
they all get translated
to the same thing,
which is, play a quiz.
And then your app could be one
of these apps that participates
in that action based on how
it has done in the past,
and personalized
results for the user.
We show a carousel of a few apps
with that kind of interaction,
and the user can play
with any of these.
So think of this.
And these are, like I
talked about earlier,
like if you are in
the meditation space,
you are in the coffee
ordering space,
you are in a health
space, a banking space,
we have built-in intents
for a lot of these.
And you can sign up
for any of those.
The third pillar that
we have for discovery
is what we call action links.
Action links are a link to
your action or to your app.
So they're pretty much like
your website URL, or a deep link
into your Android
app, and so on.
So once you create
an action link,
you can actually use
it just like your URL
on any kind of surface.
So you can use it
in your websites.
You can use it in your apps.
You can use it on
social platforms.
You can use it in your marketing
campaigns, like in your emails
and so on.
You can even use it on
billboards if you want.
The idea, really, is this
is how you tell users
that I have one
more surface which
is more optimized for
some specific use cases.
But you can actually
engage with that surface.
So it's important to
think on those lines.
Again, as I said, it's fairly
easy to create an action link.
When you go to Dialogflow,
there is a section in there
which would actually give you a
link for each of your actions.
You can create separate
ones for different intents
that your action supports.
So if you do multiple things,
like I want to track my order,
there could be a separate link.
Versus I want to place an order.
That's a separate link.
I want to reorder something.
That could be a separate
link, and so on.
Now, I talked about
discovery quite a bit.
One of the big things that a lot
of developers are interested in
is, how do I monetize
my experience?
Once I start driving
traffic to it
and start putting money
behind this Assistant app,
how do I start monetizing it?
So today we support physical
goods and transaction sales
on the platform.
We are live in seven
different markets--
US, UK, Canada, Australia,
Germany, Japan, and France.
And we are rolling out
in many more markets
over the rest of the year.
Our plan is for this
map to look a lot more
green by the end of the
year, and we're launching
multiple markets every month.
When we talk about
transactions, these
are transactions about
physical goods and services.
But these are also things like
you want to book a table, book
a car test drive, and
reservations, if you think,
or a makeover
appointment, and so on.
So transaction flows
are fairly standard,
if you think of the
building blocks.
And we support all of these
building blocks today.
You can customize it based
on your needs, and so on.
But there are three
steps for the most part.
The first one is,
you build the order,
or build a cart kind of thing.
This is where you
figure out what's
the product your
user wants to buy.
You upsell, cross-sell
other things.
What's the reservation
the user wants?
What time works for them,
and things like that.
So think on those lines.
But the first step is,
you build an order.
Once you build an order, you
propose the order to the user.
Are you ready to confirm?
Or this is the right payment
method you are using,
and so on.
So you confirm the order,
the transaction goes through.
And the third piece
is very important
when it comes to an
assistant surface,
is send updates on the order.
We have APIs where you can
push an update to orders.
For the reservation, your
reservation has been confirmed.
Or your table is now ready.
Or sorry we had to push out the
reservation by half an hour,
and things like that.
If it's a transaction,
things like,
your package has been shipped,
or it's arrived, and so on are
important to send to the
user more proactively.
We support multiple helpers to
make it easy for our developers
to build transactions.
There's a location helper if
you want the current location
of the user.
We have address helpers
if you want the delivery
address of the user.
We have payment helpers
where we can actually
help with payment instruments
Google has on file for users.
We have payment credentials for
hundreds of millions of users
through our Google Play
Google Pay offering,
and you can use those helpers.
Matt talked about you also
have account linking helpers
to make it easy for you to link
accounts with Google users.
We are also piloting
digital goods.
Digital goods are
also another way
developers can monetize
their experiences.
So when I talk
about digital goods,
think of in-app digital goods.
Like if you're in
the gaming industry,
you can sell coins and
gems and extra lives,
turns, playtime, and
things like that.
And that's a fairly big business
when it comes to digital goods.
We also announced support
subscription services,
which is if you're in the
premium content space,
like news.
Or premium subscriptions,
premium services.
This is one way to monetize
your experience, which
is through subscriptions.
Or music, for that matter.
And then the third
thing is digital assets,
like a digital book, or
movies, and stuff like that.
You can sell that on
the platform, too.
And that's other digital
goods that we support.
So across physical goods,
services, reservations,
digital goods, we
have a good portfolio
of ways our developers
can come in and create
transactional
experiences on Assistant.
When you actually
figure out the right use
case that works for a user
in Assistant surfaces,
this is something that helps
you monetize those experiences
for your users.
And then the last
piece I'll talk
about is, how do you drive
re-engagement for your users?
You have loyal
customers or you have
customers that have tried
your experience once.
How do you bring them back?
And what are the
platform constructs
we support so you
can bring users back
into your experience?
This is the same slide
I had earlier on,
is we have touchpoints with
users throughout the day.
And we offer channels
to developers
so that they can reach back to
the user at different points
of this journey.
So if you are a
use case where you
want more and more users
engage in the morning,
we have different ways
you can actually become
part of that habit for users.
Or throughout the day, or
through the evening routine,
and so on.
So let me talk about
an example of that.
We have something
that we call routines.
We have a lot of
default routines
that we have created for users.
Routines is nothing, but
it is multiple actions
bundled into a single command.
So from a user's
perspective, let's say
user says good morning, or,
hey, Google, good morning.
It kicks off a series
of actions for the user.
So it can turn off their heat.
It can move their phone
out of the silent mode.
It tells the user about their
top news, their stock portfolio
updates.
It tells about their
calendar, how their commute is
going to be to work, and so on.
And a user can configure
it, set it up, and so on.
But that's just one
example of a routine.
And you as a developer has a way
to become part of the routines,
like a tip of the day, or
the thought of the day.
Or how long is the
wait line at Caltrain?
And things like that.
So this is one way where
you can proactively
be part of users' journeys,
or your action can
be a proactive part
of users' journeys.
And there are many more
that we have out there.
This is a big engagement
point for users today
where we see users using
these routines a lot.
Because it helps them
make certain parts
of their day a lot more
seamless and efficient.
A fairly easy way for
you, the developer,
to sign up for
intents or for any
of these routines, if you go
to the console, it's an opt-in.
You sign up saying,
I want my action
to be eligible for
any of these routines.
And you turn on
that radio button,
and your option
shows up to users
to be part of that routine.
There are a couple of other
ways that we support or drive
re-engagement.
The first one is daily updates.
The thing with daily updates
is that these are the updates
that Google sends
to the user saying,
we think this is a relevant
experience for you.
Or this is a relevant
call to action for you.
We work with developers
to figure out
what are the right ones
to send to the user.
And that's one way where
we can be proactive.
The second piece is
push notifications.
This is like the
push notifications
you have on the app ecosystem.
Users opt into getting push
notifications from you,
like the example
from "Esquire" here.
And users will
proactively see every time
you want to push an update.
So this could be an
update in terms of,
there is a new
product available.
Or you signed up for a
certain deal that's available,
or a deal of the day,
or whatever it is.
So you can think of what is
relevant for your business,
but you can start
pushing out notifications
for the user through
various Google surfaces,
not just on the Assistant side.
So that's all that
I had in terms of,
how do you drive
re-engagement for your users?
We have a lot of
assets and resources
out there that you can use
to learn more about this.
We have best
practices on design,
how to create the right design.
Example is that you
want to sell tickets.
We have examples
on how you do that.
You want to create
games, we have
examples on how to create that.
And for different parts of
the different verticals,
we have a lot of
example code, example
designs that you can use.
And then, you can sign
up for a mailing list
to stay updated with all the
new and upcoming launches.
I think that's all we had.
And thank you so
much for your time.